So far, the UI that we've looked at
has been pretty boring and also pretty static.
We can introduce a lot of dynamism to our UI
extremely easily by taking advantage
of UMG's inbuilt animation authoring tools.
A widget animation is essentially
a named property of a user widget.
Unlike skeletal animations, which are a separate asset,
a widget's animations are baked directly
into the user widget and can be accessed as a property.
As such, they're given unique names upon creation.
Each animation is composed of several tracks
mirroring the pipeline used in Sequencer or Matinee.
Each track is typically linked to a widget,
and from there we can add additional subtracks
under that first widget-based track.
These subtracks are responsible for manipulating
some property of its associated widget.
So in this exact instance,
we have an animation called move.
Inside the move animation, we have tracks
all linked to an image, a border, and a spacer.
Each of these subtracks have got their properties
keyframed independently of each other,
making quite complex animations possible
with very simple modifications.
Here, we're manipulating the transform, pivots,
and opacities, but any value that we can change
over time from a gameplay point of view
can realistically be manipulated through a keyframe track.
It's worth noting that the values of particular keyframes
can't be changed at runtime.
We'll see this more in depth
with the live example at the end of the talk,
but the long and short of it is
widget animations are for static changes.
For example, we can't have an animation blend
from one color to another
where that color is chosen at runtime.
We'll need to bake this animation into the widget
during the authoring phase.
So let's talk through creating a very simple animation
using the star image from the previous slide.
As you can see, it's nothing fancy.
We're just going to be
manipulating its transform property.
However, the principles here can apply more universally
to create a much more complex animation down the line.
First things first,
we need to come down to the animation section
at the bottom of the UMG editor
and hit the green animation button.
This will create a new widget animation
embedding it in this user widget.
We'll name it move as an example.
Next, with the animation that we want to work with
selected, we'll select the widget
we want to add a track for.
In this case, we want to animate our star image.
Once that's selected, we can hit the track button
and select a track that handles the property
we want to animate.
In this instance, we'll just hit the transform button.
From here, we can keyframe any properties
within the transform that we might want to manipulate.
For this example, we're adding a keyframe
to its translation at zero,
moving its X value by just over a thousand pixels
at the one second mark,
and then moving it back to zero a second later,
creating the example on the opening slide.
And that's it.
We can now bind this animation
using the bind widget anim U property specifier
that we'll be touching on in just a second.
We'll play it outright in the blueprint graph.
This animation is now a member
of the user widget after all,
so there's nothing stopping us
from grabbing it in the blueprint backend
and simply calling play.
Now all the visual stuff's out of the way,
let's take a look at some of the code that drives it.
We won't be covering the under the hood slate magic.
We'll be touching on how we can leverage
the existing tool set Unreal offers
to author smart UI elements,
and how we could integrate them
with our gameplay systems on a code level.